alors le contrat d'engagement jeunes une
réponse adaptée vraiment la précarité
des moins de 26 ans d'échecs à tout va
pour séduire à six mois de la
présidentielle ou dispositif coûteux de
plus aux mesures au rabé on attend vos
réactions sur le comté d g verte et
france place à notre face à face
et pour en parler léon de fontaine
secrétaire général du mouvement des
jeunes communistes et porte parole de
celle d'un roussel bonsoir à l'élan de
fontaine merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés jack smith délégué national uni
union nationale inter-universitaire
bonsoir à vous aussi léon de fontaine
est ce que cette mesure elles répondent
déjà à une réelle urgence les moins de 6
ans ils sont de plus en plus dans la
précarité après cette pandémie l'urgence
est là mais cette mesure ne répond pas
aujourd'hui on nous donne cette offre on
propose 500 euros par mois et après
c'est 15 heures de formation et après
ces bonnes chances et on attend que
jeunesse se passe or emmanuel macron
nous avait promis quand il était
candidat monts et merveilles et au final
on se retrouve avec une garantie jeunes
réchauffer au micro ondes avec 2 euros
50 de plus par mois or ça ne répond pas
du tout aujourd'hui aux besoins et aux
aspirations des jeunes loin de là on est
complètement à côté et je pense qu'on
attendait autre chose du président des
jeunes malheureusement il ne va pas plus
loin il le pourrait mais il ne va pas
plus on va aller évidemment plus loin
dans le débat c'est l'objet de ce face à
face mais sur le diagnostic déjà jack
smith il ya vraiment urgence pour les
jeunes leur situation s'est empirée avec
avec la fonte des nids il fallait agir
mais il est clair que là ce qui est sûr
c'est que la crise a été en effet
engendré une crise sociale chez les
étudiants qui est qui et qui est clair
aujourd'hui
nombre de noms après les nombreux feux
successifs
confinement on a vu que quand on faisait
nos distributions alimentaires nombreux
sont les étudiants qui venaient donc
effectivement il ya clairement à une
crise sociale chez les étudiants
aujourd'hui et cette mesure elle vient
elle vient un peu alors que on a
consulté très peu les les organisations
étudiantes elle vient en fait un peu
comme un cheveu sur la soupe et qui est
en fait un rsa jeunes camoufler et on
ouvre le carnet de chèques à six mois de
la présidentielle aujourd'hui les
étudiants ils n'attendent pas une
allocation de 500 euros par part moi ils
attendent surtout qu'on les aide dans
leur insertion professionnelle et
surtout un travail à la fin de leurs
études parce que la première leurs
études parce qu'à la première précarité
aujourd'hui c'est cetc des jeunes c'est
malheureusement le chômage à la fin de
leurs 2 lors de leur formation
universitaire alors lyon de fontaine
vous disiez voilà le compte n'y est pas
c'est vrai que emmanuel maintenant c'est
souvent
présenté comme le président voilà avec
des jeunes jeunes une solution il ya eu
la garantie jeunes annoncé en juillet
dernier là c'est quoi c'est la garantie
jeunes qui disparaît au profit
de quelque chose de moins bien on a des
ambitions revues à la baisse on a des
ambitions revues à la baisse par rapport
aux annonces qu'avait fait emmanuel
macron en grande pompe il me semble 14
juillet au discours du 14 juillet aux
alentours du 14 juillet en revanche la
garantie jeunes c'est ça on est
complètement dans la continuité de la
garantie jeunes en réalité on vient
créer un nouveau sas de précarité avant
l'entrée du marché de l'emploi or
aujourd'hui ce dont nous avons besoin
c'est travail et aujourd'hui faute
d'ambition politique à la hauteur et
bien emmanuel macron propose un nouveau
contrat jeunes comme l'ont fait ses
prédécesseurs on avait eu le cpe on a vu
d'autres mesures aucune de ces mesures
n'a fonctionné pire elle a aggravé la
situation de précarité dans laquelle se
trouvait la jeunesse est aujourd'hui en
effet le compte n'y est pas aujourd'hui
moi je suis reconnaissant d'une
organisation de jeunesse on est tous les
jours devant les lycées sur les
universités et les jeunes nous disent
nous on aspire à deux choses c'est
trouver des études pour être accepté
dans la filière de son choix et après
trouver un emploi qui ait un sens qu'ils
soient utiles et qui nous permet de
vivre dignement et on n'a pas besoin
d'un nouveau contrat précaire ce qu'on
veut nous sert un emploi correctement
rémunérés et les jeunes ne demandent que
ça et ça tombe bien on en a besoin
aujourd'hui ouais ça veut dire en gros
comme on subventionne des jeunes sans
leur offrir dedans point vraiment vous
êtes sûr au moins peut-être sur cette
même ligne fixe miss alors ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui cette mesure
elle est clairement c'est un effet de
communication de la part du gouvernement
emmanuel macron le président et est un
expert en la matière et donc aujourd'hui
en fait cela c'est pour ouvrir tout
simplement encore une fois à six mois de
la présidentielle le carnet de chèques
c'est un chèque en blanc il y a
d'ailleurs beaucoup de flou autour de
cette de cette aide qu'est-ce qu'il sera
en contrepartie de ces 500 euros la
formation ou est-ce que elle sera donnée
ça sera sûrement dans les missions
locales on nous a dit ouh ouh le pôle
emploi mais aujourd'hui effectivement le
gros gros problème c'est la façon
professionnelle en 2020 vous savez
durant la crise sanitaire il ya eu un
gros problème d'insertion pro après un
bac + 5 donc un master 2 en france il a
eu la moitié des étudiants qui rentrait
sur match de travail qui était encore au
chômage au bout de six mois donc ça
c'est le réel problème des jeunes
aujourd'hui et emmanuel maquet on arrive
n'arrive pas à y répondre et ça c'est
une certitude les premiers messages l'on
parvienne à ginette chez p gaspillage
d'argent l'apprentissage est déjà en
place ça c'est vrai que c'était une des
grandes critiques de la journée l'es11
de fontaine notamment de la droite et
cette dame c'est vrai qu'on nous veut
carnet de chèques comme le dit jacques
smith à quelques mois de la
présidentielle et un petit peu de ça
aussi où vous le ressentez pas comme ça
de l'argent il en faudra ça c'est sûr
pour permettre aux jeunes de se former
sans devoir ce salariat côté leurs
études pour aller le plus loin possible
dans leur formation ça c'est indéniable
aujourd'hui en effet par contre cette
aide c'est de l'argent jeté par les
fenêtres nous ce qu'on veut et ce qu'on
revendique c'est pas la création
d'emplois et aujourd'hui on a un besoin
de l'emploi on en a besoin dans le
service public notamment l'éducation la
santé on l'a vu pendant la pandémie ou
le manque de personnel s'est fait
durement ressentir on en a aussi besoin
dans le privé pour réindustrialiser le
pays relancer le pays mais aujourd'hui
encore une fois bah oui l'argent est mal
orienté l'argent en fait on ne sait pas
où va le gouvernement
formation quelle formation si les
formations c'est les mêmes qui sont
proposées actuellement par les missions
locales
aujourd'hui les missions locales vous
dit tout en fait pour l'instant on a du
mal à les alpaguer les jeunes à aller
chercher les jeunes parce que les jeunes
il ya un taux de non recours est en fait
la réalité c'est qu'on en connaît un
certain nombre de jeunes qui ont fait le
plein un jeune une solution par exemple
eh ben on leur offre une formation en
attendant parce qu'on ne sait pas quoi
leur dire afin de les sortir des
chiffres du chômage aujourd'hui ça ne
répond pas aux besoins ni la population
ni à celui des jeunes explique pour vous
c'est pas très adapté non plus est cette
solution parce qu'on nous parle toujours
des anchois pourvoir notamment de rendre
dans le secteur de la restauration
de l'hôtellerie on a toujours du mal à
comprendre quand on est en tout cas
observateurs comme en voilà ces deux
camps entre guillemets ne se rencontrent
pas mais cette mesure c'est toujours
plus de dépenses publiques sans réelle
efficacité en fait c'est c'est toujours
la même chose effectivement et on l'a
dit c'est en fait ce que françois
hollande l'ancien président avait mis en
place avec garantie jeunes c'est juste
une garantie jeunes un peu un peu plus
large un peu plus développé mais on voit
bien françois hollande socialiste donc
c'est une mesure réellement de gauche
est aujourd'hui emmanuel macron ne
répond pas au problème de la précarité
et de l'insertion professionnelle
aujourd'hui il faut clairement développé
largement les contrats d'apprentissage
pousser les entreprises aussi en ces
temps de crise sanitaire et donc sociale
et donc sur le marché du travail pour
rentrer pour en étudier aujourd'hui
c'est compliqué donc pousser les
employeurs à a enfin justement prendre
et employés les jeunes qui me qui
rendent leur marché du travail notamment
seulement 30 ans en lui en essayant de
leur alléger les charges fiscales et
patronales tous la cdc des cdc des
solutions que nous propose que l'uni
propose depuis longtemps mais vous savez
quand vous avez une ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur qui a du mal
déjà à parler juste à dire texto
insertion professionnelle on voit bien
que que qu'ils ont pour priori plus
priorité de faire un chèque en blanc de
deux d'offrir de l'argent à tout va et
ce quelques quelque chose en fait qui ne
résout pas réellement la crise
de l'entrée de sur le marché du travail
pour un jeune d'aujourd'hui et véronique
qui nous dit une arnaque à la hauteur du
reste du quinquennat de la com pour les
présidentielles mais on sent que ce
n'est pas une phase emmanuel macron
nécessairement il ya quand même du bon
lait en de fontaine dans cette mesure
notamment peut-être cette entrevue
introduction des droits et des devoirs
c'est vrai qu'il y avait des mesures ou
là on l'envisagé au début de
subventionner son retour la ya vraiment
quand même des obligations c'est quelque
chose qui me semble juste
non non je pense que c'est un problème
de voir les choses comme ça aujourd'hui
on vient cette mesure est laisse
sous-entendre que si aujourd'hui il ya
un jeune sur cinq au chômage c'est parce
que il serait pas adapté au marché de
l'emploi et qu'il faudrait les reformer
et cetera non aujourd'hui si aujourd'hui
un jeune sur 5 près d'un jeune sur cinq
au chômage c'est parce que justement
nous n'avons pas d'emplois et donc avant
tout il faut mettre une politique en
faveur de la création d'emplois comme
j'ai dit dans le service public et je
pense que dans le privé il faut
conditionner aujourd'hui on donne des
milliards d'euros à des entreprises sans
conditionner ses aides nous ce qu'on
propose c'est de conditionner ses aides
à l'embauché de jeunes en cdi et à la
formation professionnelle et aujourd'hui
ça paraît aberrant que ce ne soit pas le
cas aujourd'hui on donne des milliards
ça c'est des vrais chèques en blanc on
donne des milliards à des entreprises
sans aucune condition d'embauché de
jeunes en cdi et donc ça fait des effets
d'aubaine aujourd'hui on embauche des
jeunes en cdd 3 mois et ça permet
derrière aux entreprises dans une
entreprise de toucher de l'argent public
et donc de nos impôts et ça c'est
scandaleux jacques smith vous êtes
d'accord
madoff en tête aujourd'hui le vrai
problème et vous vous en avez parlé
c'est l'orientation quand vous avez et
il faut c'est pour ça qu'il ya un manque
clairement de réformes structurelles de
fond est que ces petites mesurettes sont
inutiles et inefficaces
aujourd'hui hier manque de réformes
structurelles de fond qui sont qu' il
faut prendre du recul le gros problème
aujourd'hui les jeunes c'est
l'orientation après quand vous avez un
baccalauréat qui a une à taux de
réussite à près de 95% qui n'est plus du
tout un passage en entrée à une entrée
un examen d'entrée dans l'enseignement
supérieur mais justin un pseudo
certificat de fin d'études quand vous
avez la moitié des étudiants de première
année de licence qui soir double soit se
réoriente quand vous avez en france une
possibilité de pouvoir avoir un bac + 3
sans avoir passé une semaine dans
l'entreprise quand vous avez encore une
fois ce taux de horrible de 55% près de
55% de bac + 2 master 2 d'une université
qui sortent bac + 2 d'universités
françaises qui sont encore au chômage au
bout de six mois ça c'est des choses qui
sont qui c'est la réalité c'est des
choses qu'il faut régler et ce n'est
absolument pas en donnant 500 euros par
mois sans contrepartie ou presque qu'il
faut concourir des contreparties injuste
non parce que encore une fois ça sera
dans les missions locales déjà il va
falloir les créer dans ses missions
locales et donc ça sera pas fait tout de
suite donc c'est une vaste arnaque et
puis encore une fois ces formations
elles ne sont jamais abouti ça a été dit
j'avais très peu de jeunes ont pu être
formé et trouver un emploi grâce à ce
genre de grâce à ce genre de vous qui
n'êtes pas au plaisir oui je dis enfin
il ya un problème d'orientation
aujourd'hui c'est certain surtout qu'on
oblige les jeunes à se sélectionner à
s'orienter beaucoup plus tôt notamment
dès la 3e mais aujourd'hui le premier
problème on l'a vu c'est la sélection
entre l'université et la précarité
étudiante aujourd'hui s'il ya autant
d'échecs à l'université c'est parce
qu'on a un étudiant sur deux qui est
obligé de se salarier à côté de ces
études est à côté qui est obligé d'aller
faire la queue devant des organismes de
distribution alimentaire et nous on a
une mesure concrète là dessus c'est la
création d'un revenu étudiants au dessus
du seuil de pauvreté pour tous les
étudiants pour les sortir de cette
précarité un revenu sans contrepartie un
revenu la contrepartie c'est d'étudier
voilà c'est la vérité en réalité
l'ambition c'est d'avoir la jeunesse la
mieux formée parce qu une jeunesse
formée c'est celle qui sera capable de
répondre aux défis que nous avons devant
nous et lui n'y est bien d'accord et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut regarder ces
allocations avec avec du recul et vous
devez être bien bien content de ce2 ce2
de cette mesure puisque en fait ce n'est
qu'à rsa jeunes camouflé alors certes
qui n'est pas aussi large et qui ne
touchent pas autant de d'étudiants que
vous voudriez mais c'est clairement
toujours plus de dépenses publiques avec
toujours moins d'efficacité et donc
c'est clairement quelque chose qui va
dans votre sens et qui ne va pas dans
une meilleure orientation des étudiants
et des jeunes et une meilleure insertion
professionnelle et c'est ça la leur
problème et c'est la première paire
qualité des jeunes c'est ne pas avoir de
bouloire attention succès 91 mille
lycéennes et lycéens bacheliers qui
n'ont pas été acceptées dans
l'enseignement supérieur si ce n'est pas
une sélection à grande échelle je ne
vois pas ce que c'est et c'est ce que
vous vous proposez et pour le coup ça
remplit les un million et demi de jeunes
qui se retrouvent sans emploi une
formation directement et ça vous pouvez
pas dire que c'est une mesure que nous
nous portons au contraire c'est une
mesure que vous défendez depuis mai avec
95% de taux de réussite du bac vous
savez ce n'est plus une entrée dans
l'enseignement supérieur pour d'autres
c'est un pseudo certificat de faire des
de d2 d'études secondaires qui ne peut
plus rien dire et donc aujourd'hui quand
vous pouvez quand vous voyez la stat de
2,2 de la moitié de dna à la fin de
l'heure et lakic issoire double soit se
réoriente il y a un gros problème
d'orientation il faut clairement tapé là
dessus que le ministère d'enseignement
supérieur prennent en charge cette
problématique merci en tout cas foulée
de jack smith et léon de fontaine
d'avoir accepté ce fait ça se passait
avant de nous quitter à je voudrais